. All right.
I want to warn everybody there is some Trump
content on today's program.
Donald Trump, after being essentially out
of the public eye for the last two months
of his presidency and since leaving the White
House, did a bunch of interviews yesterday.
In a sense, he did four, if you include his
bizarre call in to eulogize Rush Limbaugh
on Fox News, which we'll talk about a little
bit later.
He did announce another late night interview
on Fox News with Sean Hannity, which we'll
cover tomorrow.
He did an interview with Owen, which I won't
cover it all, but he did a Newsmax interview,
which is where I want to start today.
And the big picture of this interview is that
Donald Trump has learned absolutely nothing
from being president.
He has learned nothing from losing in November.
He has just decided to continue making his
false claims that he won the election, that
Joe Biden stole it.
Now, let's see if we can learn anything from
this interview.
Let's jump right in.
The topic of Rush Limbaugh's death came up.
Donald Trump took it as an opportunity to
tell the big lie once again that he won the
election and that Rush Limbaugh believed it
as well.
You know, just got he just got a bad a bad
deal.
It was what he had was something that was
not going to be there, was not going to be
there.
And he understood that.
But he wanted to get past the election and
he made it easily and he thought we won the
election.
We did win the election.
As far as I'm concerned, it was disgraceful
what happened, totally disgraceful.
But Rush wanted to get by the election and
he did it and he was proud of that.
The casual nature with with with which Donald
Trump still says after causing the riot that
he won, confirms he learned absolutely nothing.
And then Donald Trump, just like he used to,
bragging about fake polls in which he is supposedly
now beloved.
He was asking the big question.
He was asked the big question about running
in 2024.
He didn't commit, but he had many other things
to say.
See if you can make sense out of any of them.
But we have tremendous support.
I won't say yet, but we have tremendous support.
And I'm looking at poll numbers that are through
the roof.
You saw what happened yesterday.
We went up.
We get a the guy get some pizza.
My numbers go up and I figure that one out.
Let's say somebody gets impeached.
Typically, your numbers would go down.
They would go down like like a dead balloon.
But the numbers are very good.
They're very high.
I think they're higher than they were before
the election and they were high at the election.
And they like the job.
Look, we did a great job.
We built rebuilt our military.
Think of it.
We lowered taxes, got rid of regulations.
How about spaceports?
Just spaceports.
Force alone would be a big achievement at
first time in 74 years, a new branch of the
U.S. military.
So and all of the things we've done, what
on earth is Donald Trump talking about?
His numbers are good and high.
He lost the election by a record number of
votes.
And while, yes, the majority of the Republican
electorate still is behind Trump, even those
numbers have tapered off a little bit.
Also, it's not like there are that many examples
of approval ratings during impeachment, he
says, oh, typically approval ratings are down.
During impeachment, mine were up.
Bill Clinton did fine in approval while being
impeached.
Before that, it was before the polling error.
So on the basic facts, as usual, Donald Trump
is just wrong or clueless.
This same type of verbal Rorschach tests that
we've become accustomed to during Trump's
presidency, we're continuing as we are left
to try to kind of unravel and decipher what
Trump is talking about.
Listen to this.
And the border.
We built the wall.
Mexico is getting ready to pay for the war.
We're going to judge him at the border, small
thing, and Mexico would have paid for the
war.
They were all set.
They gave us 28000 troops to police it before
it got built.
And now you see what's happening.
The president of Mexico is a great gentleman,
by the way, but he put 28000 troops on our
border at my request.
And we didn't pay for that.
And he we kept we kept the border beautiful.
And now you take a look at what's going on
at the border.
It's a disgrace.
Hundreds of thousands of people are going
to be pouring in.
Mexico was never going to pay for the wall.
That lie won't die.
Trump now wants us to believe that he was
just seconds away from putting in place some
kind of a border tax on people coming in from
Mexico to indirectly pay for the wall.
He was never going to do it.
He's been talking about it for years.
It didn't matter if he got a second term or
not.
He just won't stop telling that lie.
But it's simply a lie.
And just all over the place.
And if you were watching there, you might
have seen when the camera cut back to the
host, Greg Kelly, on Newsmax, he looked sort
of exasperated and looking around and thinking
of how he might be able to get control back
of the interview, something that's pretty
tough to do.
Donald Trump then asked about being suspended
from Twitter, and this got really weird.
Trump sort of listed the number of followers
he believed he had on on various networks
and claims that Twitter very is very boring
now without him.
I mean, just the opposite.
They really wanted me manpower, power.
And, you know, I had 89 million, but that
was because they held it back.
And then on top of that, I had 36 million
or 39 million on BOTUS and we had other sites
where we had millions and millions of people.
So we have, I guess, about as big as it gets
and likewise on on Facebook.
And they all want that.
And part of the problem is mechanically, they
can't handle it because it's too many people.
It's bigger than they are by many times and
they want to.
And I'll tell you, it's not the same if you
look at what's going on with if you look at
what's going on with Twitter, I understand
it's become very boring and millions of people
are leaving.
They're leaving it because it's not the same.
And I can understand that.
And so we'll see what happens.
We're negotiating with a number of people.
And there's also the other option of building
your own.
I mean, you can literally build your own set,
but we were being really harassed on Twitter.
Did you notice that?
He said there that part of the problem is
that his following is too big, I guess, for
Facebook to handle on a technical level, it's
just such a ridiculous thing to say mechanically.
They can't handle what is he talking about?
And it doesn't matter how obviously untrue
these things are, Donald Trump has a unique
ability to tell laughable, obvious, provable
lies, as if there is nothing to it just so
casually telling them.
And that was the Newsmax interview.
Greg Kelly visibly struggling to get control
of it.
Tomorrow, we're going to look at the Hannity
interview, which is a whole other level to
look at.
I want to I don't even have time today to
devote to it.
I'm going to save it for tomorrow.
But we'll take a break later.
We will talk about Rush Limbaugh.
And I have I have quite a few things I want
to go over with Rush Limbaugh and we'll have
some clips of Trump calling into Fox during
the daytime to you eulogize Rush in a way
that is completely self-serving and narcissistic.
What else would you expect?
So Trump out of the bunker, back on media.
We'll have more coverage of it on the Instagram
page.
Follow us on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And you can follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman